and i buy the groceries and your deal is
that you're supposed to help with
laundry and you haven't been doing it
and now i'm underwearless
my ball sack is not this chair
and you don't care
no one asks you to use all your boxers
within three days i do it once a week
every weekend days
you did this last week too you have no
you weren't even around last week i've
been working on your end of the deal
you know what i've been working so good
on my end of the deal that i even got
you food they did a collab
you
you are my university i just want to put
you first the only reason why i doubt
those are the lyrics is because every
time you sing a song
never the lyrics kill me that is right
there we go with the accents again in
five four three
two
one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast
we have my co-host for the day
mariel song
there's no crowd here nobody's cheering
for you at all whatsoever what the hell
are you doing
did you ever perform when you were a kid
like in front of crowds absolutely you
never did anything like a church or
anything i have one that i remember when
i was in third grade i don't know what
we're doing but we're on stage and i was
had to hold i had to hold on to this
like paper
and i remember that you know how like
you're on stage you have spotlights
coming through
it's my first time dealing with
spotlight and
i don't know if i was being dramatic or
not but i was just like okay i'm gonna
fall
and then i'm gonna faint that's all i
was thinking
so i think that shows that no i don't
no i don't do it you never performed
anything as a kid they didn't make you
sing dance or anything like that
at church i was virgin mary
so all i had to do was carry a
roll
a roll of a towel
oh for the baby yeah
that's so funny that's pretty much it
and banned concerts i remember as a kid
going to church and having ah every year
we had to like do a a christmas song
we had gotta perform all that other
stuff there's a video of me somewhere
i'll hopefully i'll find it when i get
back
no i didn't like singing when i was a
kid it was funny be like little david
singing first of all i was never little
so
like i specifically remember this
videotape it's somewhere but in this
videotape
everybody's wearing a white turtleneck
first of all
because that's what we had to do it was
for christmas and we were supposed to
see christmas carols or whatever in
front of the adult the adult uh ministry
yeah
i'm at this point i had my growth spurt
so i how old were you we're i'm in sixth
grade
i'm like seven inches tall than
everybody else
i look like one of the teachers
and i'm just in the corner with my bowl
cut and this turtleneck with like food
stains all over it oh my god cause it's
so white
because i used to always get i was a
dirty ass kid i bet you and i just
remember just sitting there just i look
so stupid why do i have to do this
because i'm so much bigger than
everybody else and then no but nobody
else had the growth spurt yet but i was
like the first one so i was a giant but
i used to hate performing i used to hate
doing praise i hated singing i hated
doing the whole um
uh
father you and your kid father abraham
had many sons
many sons of father abraham no i am one
of them and so are you
so let's just praise the lord right arm
father abraham amen
me uh
[Music]
making fun of korean people
[Music]
like you were imitating the korean
language
no that's an actual phrase it's called
come like when it's like fuzzy it's just
like i could barely remember uh cause
now that you mention it yeah at church
we did a lot of performance like i have
pictures of being like pretending i'm
dancing or whatever there was this one i
don't know if he did this but it was a
traditional korean
folk song or something where what the
hell
basically you partner up with uh
opposite
gender
uh
and
you do this like
flirty dance where you i know that way
you know what i think um
it was north korea did that remember the
little girl in north korea she performed
it
i don't recall
oh but it's like they're flirting like
yeah
you know
yeah actually it is yeah they like cover
their face and they go hello and then
peekaboo
[Laughter]
yeah that's i know we used to do that
a group performance i think i've done it
multiple times anyway yeah i've done it
before now i think about it i did hip
hop dance before like yeah you have
performed then yeah how do you forget
that why do you i don't
i don't know how do you forget that i
don't know because i'm forgetful it
doesn't retain in my brain but why do
you ask
because we're on a podcast i'm asking
questions
did you forget that we were shooting
right now it was just a random question
interrogated right now why do you ask it
was just the first question i'm like you
must have brought it up for a reason but
also you maybe just asked as a random
question oh
yes i have to
did you forget that we're recording
right now
she's like why'd you ask she's all
threatened
no uh so when i came to like a group
performance i actually loved it i
enjoyed it i don't remember any fear but
when i had to do
flute recital
where you're up in the stage by yourself
i freaked out i'm always off wait for
you you were is this for church no it's
just uh i said oh my god i just
remembered i had piano recitals too oh
yeah i did not i hated it i hate it i
freaking hated it from church or it's
like a private tutor no my parents well
i wanted to learn how to play the piano
when i was really young and then but the
type of music that i wanted to play my
parents didn't teach me right so we had
a piano teacher she was a korean lady
and
she wasn't from our church actually but
she was referred to somebody from church
and but then we learned how to play you
know
classical piano yeah you know mozart and
all the [ __ ] i didn't want to learn any
of that stuff so the the piano that i
was that was being taught to me wasn't
the one that i wanted to learn so we did
it for like a few years then my brother
had to learn piano because i did it and
he hated me for it because he didn't
want to learn piano but i did and then i
it was it just wasn't the type of music
that i enjoyed though what's the type of
music you like i want to learn like jazz
you know even as a little kid i want to
learn jazz and stuff because i used to
watch the cosby show and so the cosby
show like bill cosby how come you like
the cosby show the cosby show was the
[ __ ] it was like the funniest show to me
as i got older it became funnier and
funnier but it was just a really funny
funny funny sitcom i don't think i ever
had the chance to watch the cosby show
when i was younger like at that age
maybe like in middle school high school
when it was rerun
but not when i was yeah well i was we
were i was super young too so i'm pretty
sure everything that i saw was a rerun
so by the time that i started watching
it was probably like in this last season
but then i started watching the reruns
when i was a kid they played jazz there
oh dude uh heathcliff huxtable on the
show which was bill cosby he loved jazz
and so oh yes yes i remember he was a
huge jazz fan so they'd always talk
about jazz so i wanted to learn how to
play jazz piano but instead i got
classical music and i hated it they
wouldn't let you play jazz or maybe
i don't think the teacher knew how to
play this yeah yeah like you need a not
in korean community which is kind of
weird though because i i wonder i don't
think any korean kid learned piano for
what they wanted to learn it for it was
just something that you did because
almost every korean can learn how to
play the piano yeah it's like uh
i think you know in some community
playing violin is a basic thing did you
used to get hit if you didn't get the
notes right no
oh maybe because i'm a girl but no i got
hit my hands got hit with a stick pop
what the fudge are you kidding me this
lady was [ __ ] harsh man
clearly yeah oh no i i i can't even
count the um
the uh
i can't count the amount not amount like
how many times i had to
get a new teacher because the amount of
times i had to move around
so i think i have maybe one piano
teacher every year that's crazy so i
didn't get to learn much i mean
also i don't think i was i didn't like
piano when i was growing up it just
seemed like more of a
it's like kind of equip
equivalent to reading a book where
it was a
it wasn't a reward for me it was the
opposite so performing always gave me
anxiety i hated it i hated performing so
much and even to this day because i
perform now i i don't know if i like it
i think i just do it
because i like uh develop the skill for
it but performing gives me anxiety
here's the thing
do you get anxiety just being out there
like if you're there
solo versus there with a group of folks
that you know
does exactly same thing it doesn't
matter really i don't know what it is
but i've i've never liked crowds i never
liked big groups of people i don't like
it at all i'm a major introvert and i
think the crazy thing is i think like uh
pandemic made it worse because
the less i had to be around people this
is a skill that you have to develop over
time and one of those things too it's
like
whether you're an introvert an extrovert
right you can't in my personal opinion
i'm pretty sure
there's like psychological documents
that could back this up you can't turn
an introvert into an extrovert you can
only learn how to navigate through
social yeah social situations right yeah
my whole life i assumed i was an
extrovert right only because i wanted to
i didn't like performing but i enjoyed
the
i enjoyed what happened after i
performed right so after i do my set
after i played music or whatever i
enjoyed getting it over with and i
enjoyed that other people were laughing
and that was the the feeling that you
chase but when you give me the option of
not having to do it i don't think i i'd
do it right so let's say
and i think that's what i mean by like
pandemic makes it worse because pandemic
when pandemic happened all the shows
stopped all the traveling stopped and
then it stopped becoming habit now a lot
of the stuff that we do now is here it's
inside the house i'm not really doing
much uh in terms of uh outside of this
house because now we're doing podcasting
and everything else so that social
anxiety started i think has gotten worse
than it was before like yeah i can still
go out i can go ahead and talk schmooze
or whatever but it's definitely
something that takes a lot more energy
out of me than it did before because i'm
not in practice anymore and if you don't
practice this [ __ ] as an introvert it
[ __ ] you up
because if you don't have to be around
it you don't especially when you're
older when you're older if you don't
want to be around [ __ ] you don't have to
be around you have that choice the as
you get older your level of [ __ ] um
the amount of [ __ ] that you can deal
with decreases and you have the option
of not being around people like when
you're in high school right there are
some people in the group in your high
school that you just deal with just
because it's annoying because they're
just there they're part of the group if
i say something it makes makes things
awkward whatever i'll just deal with
them yeah when you're older you could
just be like i don't got to be a part of
this group yeah it's harder when you're
younger because you have all this
external pressure when you're older you
don't feel anything at all especially
when you find a partner that you love
and you care about and you get married
you carry even [ __ ] less because now
like the people that matter the most are
going to be your wife your kids your
parents and that's really about it i
wonder what what it's going to be like
now because like so many companies out
there are now you know announcing i have
been announcing that they're
indefinitely
working remotely
so
those who had daily opportunities to
socialize and kind of
build that ex
skill cause that's i actually i'm one of
them too the fact that i haven't been
doing the usual routine of meeting folks
and everything that when i
i thought i was more social and i'm okay
because i've been going out and about
you know we go hawaii and stuff i see my
friends but recently i found out that
i'm actually very awkward now like my
body reacts without
even me knowing about it and so
i'm wondering how the society is gonna
be now the fact that so many big
companies are now working remotely so
we're
uh
we have the
in in a way introvert has the advantage
of staying you know not having to deal
with the social
anxiety but also they're they might be
losing that experience or that skill
like you how you said that you're out of
practice i feel like what's gonna happen
like how much more awkward are we gonna
be it's tough and i don't know if people
agree with this or not but
social skills are very [ __ ] important
um and it's so hard
it's harder for us as introverts right
we have we have a steeper hill to climb
can you know conversely with people who
are uh
extroverts because they get energy from
being around people when they're around
a group of people when they do group
activities when they aren't by
themselves
they feel energized by other people's
vibe and energy and everything else like
that for us
if you are an introvert and you guys
might know this too if you are an
introvert when you go outside you
socialize it takes from you it makes you
exhausted you're when you come home
you're tired you you enjoy the
interaction maybe or something like that
but you feel like people have been
taking from you what about your close
friends like when you have one-on-one
time with your close friends i think
those are fine right
[Music]
one-on-one
um
fine because it's not a lot of people
right but even then it's it's a select
amount of people that could be around
for that long it's not one-on-one with
everybody like there are certain people
who want to hang out with me one-on-one
and i know that talking to them is
[ __ ] exhausting so i i avoid them
like yeah that's true just because we
don't
for some reason the conversation always
leads to something that that takes away
from me a lot versus us just being
around each other and being able to vibe
there's very few people that i could do
with that with where i could hang out
almost every day with like one of them
is like gabo the other one now is khalif
like i could hang out with him pretty
much virtually two three times a week
and we just joke around and [ __ ] around
and it's and it's a good time yeah um
the hard part about that is like
finding out what type of introvert there
are people out there who are just like
debilitated where they only want to be
by themselves maybe one other person and
everything else stresses them out the
problem with that is like that i've been
seeing with people during pandemic is
when they interact with um people when
they try to date dating has been a huge
issue for people who have been
introverted who haven't talked to people
who haven't practiced the skill of
speaking to people because talking to
somebody online versus face to face is
so different oh yeah it's not the same
there are there are physical cues that
you now have to be mindful for that you
didn't have to deal with yeah all you
were dealing with was with the with the
words and just interpreting what these
words means within this small like
digital realm yeah well now when you're
with face-to-face with somebody now you
have to analyze oh why do they move
their hand this way am i making them
feel uncomfortable they're kind of
pulling back a little bit you have
visuals you know that's what happened to
me like over the weekend i went to this
one korean restaurant to have dinner
with a friend and it was like crowded
but i mean i would say in my head i was
like wow this is actually kind of
crowded but at the same time like i've
been like at disneyland you know crowd
space before so i was like oh it's not a
problem and then the survey came up and
i was gonna
um i was gonna order in korean
but something with her energy or the
weight i think she was looking at me and
i think that kind of threw me off of
course she would be looking at me
because she's waiting to for me to say
something
my voice just changed and i didn't even
hear my voice change so she started
laughing and i was like i'm so i i was
so dumb i was just confused and i looked
at my friends she was she also laughed
and
i was like okay i'm ready to order so i
ordered she laughed and i asked my
friends like what happened why are you
guys laughing she's like
didn't you hear your voice it changed
and i couldn't tell if you were like
joking or what that was and then later
on she kind of sees that i was very
awkward and like anxious
um but yeah stuff like that it's that
i'm talking to people every day that's
my job
but
the energy that i'm getting from people
i'm not used to that when they're so
close to me i kind of there's so much
more things to assess that you didn't
have to assess yeah
so it's it's uncomfortable now that's so
that's you know what's funny is that
because of because i'm noticing this
about myself i'm actually having hard
time to reach out folks who've been
reaching out to me to hang out
because i i feel like i'm not in a good
stage right now
to meet people like i feel like if we
meet up i will be awkward
i mean i feel fine with friends right
and at the end of the day you've seen me
around people like no no nobody would
know that i'm an introvert no nobody
knows everybody thinks i'm [ __ ]
extroverted
they think i am you know do you tell
them that you're an introvert and you
hate it to be out in the public like
well my close friends no i don't like
big crowds they they know that for a
fact right so like i've okay so for an
example
there was one friend who uh
we were supposed to have dinner with
just uh two people right it was me
another friend and another friend well
little did i know this person invited
like seven other people that he was
kicking it with in k-town at the time
and that [ __ ] irritated the [ __ ] out of
me right not because i wanted to hang
out one-on-one and have a great
conversation it's just that this person
knows that i don't deal well with crowds
and specifically what happens because of
my anxiety my anxiety starts to spike
and then what happens is
i look like i [ __ ] hate people
it's very apparent in my face like
people have seen this where
where i meet somebody i don't know and
as they're speaking it looks like i want
to [ __ ] kill them you know and it has
nothing to do with them i'm irritated at
that point i was just irritated at the
situation that this person knows that i
have social anxiety to the max and they
invite seven people that i don't [ __ ]
know they're drunk as hell talking super
loud touching me doing all this other
[ __ ]
and then just my anxiety starts to rise
and then i try to mask my anxiety with
anger
and then because i don't know what it
does but anger makes you seem like
you're a more confident person but
really i'm just irritated all around and
so like those type of things like my
close friends know i had this issue
so for all those college shows you have
done how how did you
deal with i have to i have to mentally
prepare myself that's not easy you know
we were so so marielle and i like was to
this morning was it yesterday
it was yesterday but we had like this so
in in the morning basically you know she
wants she wanted me to go to an event
and then my knee-jerk reaction is i
don't want to go typically what happens
with like
big events or people when people are
there i
immediately choose to opt out and just
like i was saying before
if it's a situation that i can control
that i that i don't have to be in i'm
most likely going to choose the option
where i don't want to be there because i
know my behaviors
like
when i when my anxiety spikes i try to
cover it up with just being very stoic
not having any emotions but that comes
off as me becoming really aggressive
this is what happens all the time and
it's just a lot to deal with so my
knee-jerk reaction is that i can't do it
now i did have something during the day
but i immediately went to no can't do it
when really i should have taken the time
to really think i can and i think even
from mario she didn't understand how
much work it takes for me to be in
social settings i have to mentally
prepare myself all the time
it's like before i do a show
this show is booked out a month ahead so
now i mentally prepare myself okay
there's going to be a lot of people
around me
um
what about something like sun foods
where you're in a crowd but you're not
technically interactive but then you got
good amount of folks around you yeah but
i don't have to interact with them
though because i'm shooting
right but
so that's okay that's fine i'm not
interacting with them though i'm just in
a group setting but everybody's away
from me because i'm with crew
people aren't really next to me or what
about the crew themselves that's fine
i've known them now for what
six seven years
like john andrew luis
and then like the crew people we've
already met like this is it's it's it's
kind of hard to explain right because
especially when you're in a social
setting where you when you're supposed
to be social that shit's annoying that's
why i don't like doing weddings
weddings bothered me the most because of
me having to socialize with people that
i literally could give a [ __ ] less about
having to smile make them laugh do all
this other stuff it's obnoxious like i
[ __ ] hate it
i mean there is difference between not
liking it because everybody has to do
that versus you have anxiety for that
yeah so which one is it
it's not different
it's kind of goes hand in hand because
people i mean like for example i have to
go to weddings right where i meet folks
that i don't know and
i mean
i would rather use that time talking to
strangers than and i rather use that
time to talk to friends that i care
about but then i also need to cater you
know sometimes to folks that i don't
know
it's not i don't like it
but see that's the difference what i'm
saying you just don't like it no that's
what i'm saying like you said that you
don't like it so i'm asking is that i
don't like it because i the anxiety that
happens it's like because there's
anxiety people yeah i don't like it and
also just don't like being around people
i don't [ __ ] know
so it's like it's it's compounded with
everything
like these social settings are hard like
it's it's difficult
i just hide it very well and i'm also
i've also just kind of learned how to
deal with it this is the same [ __ ] my
dad deals with all the time i know for a
fact now that i'm older my dad has
social anxiety to the [ __ ] max but he
was a pastor so he learned how to
mask his stuff through
you know the religious work that he had
to do there was a goal in mind right it
was that he wanted to spread the word or
the love of god but if you look at my
dad's circle my dad's circle is very
small you don't ever see my dad go into
social situations that are big with a
lot of people and i and i watch and i
observe him around a group of people he
doesn't know he's very awkward
and i can see his anxiety i see the same
[ __ ] that i deal with that he has so i
don't know if i learned it from him or
if i picked up these behaviors from him
um but i've i recognized this in myself
super early on when i started trying to
stand up when i was 16
and i couldn't figure out why before i
mean everybody when they perform they
feel anxious right but then i started
breaking it down even when i was super
young as a teenager it's like how do you
like performing but you freak out every
[ __ ] time why is it that you can't
even order food at a restaurant and you
start to freak out like that i used to
not be able to order food
i couldn't go into a restaurant and
order food off a menu because the menu
selection was would freak me the [ __ ]
out and i was afraid that if i ordered
something uh i would order something
wrong it wasn't right they would
question my what i would order this is
what anxiety does it puts you in this
weird [ __ ] spiral and you start going
to the stupid [ __ ]
so when i recognize that i had the same
issue that my dad would have and that's
this would be like something small of
like the anxiety of like not knowing how
to speak english
so
my dad would always have me um
do all the
internet stuff the bill stuff and he
would have me talk on the phone and i
would deal with anxiety because i didn't
know what i was talking about and i
freak out because i don't know what i'm
talking about which is why if you notice
one of my biggest habits is that i tend
to over research things it's because it
helps with my anxiety it helps me
if i know these things that are going to
happen i can make adjustments later on
so i like to be three or four steps
ahead but when it comes to
going out and about you don't like to
plan it yeah because there's nothing bad
that's going to happen like what's going
to happen if i go to hawaii and then
do you see what i'm saying
well but if i but like for example
if i start cooking a dish
right i buy all these ingredients well
that one yeah there's a residual burn
something doesn't happen i just wasted a
whole crap ton of food i could go back
to the grocery store rework this start
it from scratch that's different if i'm
traveling to hawaii like a vacation i
literally could care less because i
don't have an end result that i'm trying
to achieve i'm just there just to have a
good time so my anxiety doesn't spike
there too and plus i'm not around people
either so
it doesn't really matter but my dad has
dealt with this for a very long time and
when i recognized it myself i started
making steps to to kind of learn how to
mask or change it or build the habit of
being social and that was
through me observing other people being
social i felt like an alien
like sometimes when you have like social
anxiety you feel like you're an alien
trying to learn how other people
interact with other human beings
that's what it feels like because you
look at other people and you go wow how
the [ __ ] do they do that is that why you
like that one dude who like learned of
language
within a week fluently and he was
talking about how he likes to mimic
so no no i like that just because it's
novelty it's like a white guy well
that's what you sound like when you say
that because that's what he said too
yeah for me it's just more like
how do they do that like i used to uh
one of my buddies like when we used to
go to clubs right when we were kids
kids like we were like 17 18 years old
and i would watch this guy talk to any
girl
and before i would talk to a girl i
would just be sitting in my head
spinning you know what happens if i talk
to her what do i say where do i take the
conversation what if she says no what if
she doesn't like me i'm not that
attractive do i have to be funny what
more and all these things would spit in
my head and this [ __ ] would just
walk up like what's up man my name is
blah blah blah and then she'd be like
i'm good and he walks away he goes i
then goes to another girl
goes to another girl and i started
learning oh this guy doesn't have this
anxiety when it comes to approaching
people talking people when he's in a
group setting he talks to anybody and
everybody
and i started picking up his habits
because i'm like okay
he did this he didn't die
he made he
so i started like kind of when i started
approaching women in these open settings
i started just copying what he does
and but he didn't have the feelings that
i had though i still felt it i just
started masking how i felt and i started
um doing this thing where i started
accepting these negative outcomes that
would happen that wouldn't kill me
it's like ah i got rejected damn this
[ __ ] hurts you know but i'd be like it's
cool and i would pretend like it didn't
hurt move on but afterwards when i come
home i'm like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] sucks
i think a lot of people are like that
though don't you think so in that kind
of sense of like
um
how you feel at the end of it
yeah i think a lot of people do like
they cover
you know most of their feeling because
they don't want to show their weakness
but then at home they're just like
crying yeah for sure and i think a lot
of people do feel that way um i did a
similar thing too but i don't know if
it's anxiety or lack of social skills
that i had because i used to also watch
folks whether like how people interacted
and some of the phrases people use like
i literally would draw notes i would
like write the note uh write down the
notes of phrases that they use or like
when they use it why they use it the
intonation of it so that when i so i
could i could be more
i don't know americanized or i could
feel more like i know what i'm saying
kind of
if not i feel like i was like a ghost
yeah but i don't like
i had similar experience in that kind of
stuff but i don't know if it's an
anxiety
i don't know i'm always a nervous person
like a talk you know socializing was
always a hard thing for me and i learned
how to cope with it too
you're really good at public speaking
like
when
you had to like
when you didn't know that you had to be
in front of a wedding and talk
you
pulled it through so well but did you
see the the mental
anguish that i went through before dad
is very
realistic i i'm like realistic what is
the word like i would totally
i would have been sweating i think you i
was sweating i sweated through my whole
[ __ ] shirt you killed it if i were
there i would have said stuff and people
will be like what is she saying but
that's the interesting thing too though
that's why i'm saying it's all practice
and you yeah you did really well so when
people assume that um oh he's a
naturalist [ __ ] this has never
been natural for me it has never ever
been natural for me this is super like i
said i couldn't order a burger from
mcdonald's because i would freak the
[ __ ] out i would literally freak out how
do you order so well now you make fun of
me that i can't order exactly it's all
because of the reasons that you said and
i'll tell you this too though we all
know about projection we project stuff
out from other people that we hate him
the qualities that we see in ourselves
so when i see you do that i see that
quality i hate it myself then why do you
have to lash it at all i don't lash out
yeah you do you'll be like oh my gosh
come on everyone's waiting for you okay
the the difference is
can't say the difference the more you do
that more anxiety goes up you should
know that dude
let me tell you this though the
difference is is how how you are
inconsiderate of everybody else i'm
trying to be considerate i get anxiety
from what what i do is i don't go in
line and sit there and ask a
barista 30 questions about what the
drink is i step out of line because i'm
considerate i said you guys go first so
i could think about it you don't do that
at coffee places
coffee place i'm talking about that one
incident you mentioned it to everyone in
hawaii
and then yet you were still saying come
on
and you're putting that anxiety even
higher you i i even said it all i was
like you're making me very anxious here
i'm like you should know that you should
not do that if you know it you know what
i would have done i would have said get
everybody else to order can you come
back to me in five minutes this podcast
is brought to you by purple by friends
it's funny there are all these gimmicks
that promise a great night's sleep and i
don't care what kind of toppers there
are or how heavy your damn blanket is
it's just lipstick on a stupid pig if
you're sleeping on a terrible mattress
your sleep will be terrible it's that
simple that's why i recommend sleeping
on a purple
mattress the gel flex grid is amazingly
supportive for your back and legs i
gotta tell you man if i'm not sleeping
on my purple i ain't sleeping that well
at all every time i travel and i don't
have my purple mattress i think about it
i think about my purple mattress and i
cry yes real tears it soaks into that
stupid mattress because it's not my
purple
mattress oh getting a great night's
sleep starts with having a great
mattress get a purple mattress go to
purple.com brain10 and use codebrain10
for a limited time you can get 10 off
any order of 200 or more that's purple
dot com slash brain ted code brain 10
for 10 off any order of 200 or more
purple.com brain 10 promo code brain 10.
you think she that would have worked
because she would be like i want to
order like she wanted to do everyone she
would do that that's what a waitress
would do when you're anxious you can't
really think like that then let me order
for you i did i asked you what do you
and you said just pick whatever exactly
that doesn't help big whatever here's
the thing the reason why the reason why
i gave itself the reason why i say you
can order whatever
is basically because i've seen you eat
rotten food and enjoy it
so no matter what you ordered on the
menu it would have been fun rude how
rude how rude i have literally seen this
woman eat spoiled food later on her
stomach hurts she looks me dead into my
eyes and goes i think it was rotten and
i'm like listen where did i enjoy it i
would go where's the food she goes i
hate it i'm like what the [ __ ]
why
why why would you eat it it's spoiled
she goes i don't want to waste money i'm
like it's already wasted it's it's
spoiled you know what that's what you
get don't overspend
overspend what are you talking about
what are you doing you buy costco size
i'm like there's only two people in the
house why do we always have to get
costco eat most of it
you must have it exactly
i just try to eat and then by the time i
eat i'm like oh it's spoiled tell my
goodness i really would i mean she's she
is getting better when she stops
yeah
she stopped she goes i think this is
spoiled i'm not going to eat it and i
saw her throw it away i'm like wow
growth see i
see when people don't push you and give
anxiety
then it works okay you just need to give
them some space david you should know
about this come on now why am i teaching
you guys i did give you space you just
so
inconsiderate dude
you are inconsiderate aren't you joking
no
yes i'm okay okay good as i was gonna
say do we need to turn this off because
we need to have a chat because i'm so
considerate that it's over considerate
i would spend the whole day with someone
that i don't even know and you spend my
whole time trying to cheer that person
up yeah we we were talking about this
too where
you know
i think
one of the things that i think a lot of
us do too is
we forget how much
relationships are very reciprocal right
so mary was talking about this situation
is somebody who's very i'm joking about
the inconsiderate thing that those are
these are all jokes when we laugh these
are jokes um
i made it serious so he would stop
making fun of me yeah this little
[ __ ] but um
she's a little over
overconsiderate in the sense that she
tends to put other people's emotions
first before herself to the point where
sometimes when she does that she tends
to lash out at me because she does
something she goes well i did that for
you i never asked her to do it for me
but what happens is that when you kind
of do things for other people and not
for yourself when you don't get the end
result that you want you tend to get
hurt from it right because and the
crappy situation about that is that you
can't control how other people feel
about stuff that you do for them
and so when you don't get that end
result you get hurt because you did it
for them even though
the end result is it's a wild card you
don't know what's going to happen yeah
you shouldn't it's hard i don't want to
expect that but i'm expecting something
exactly so like when you give you give
out of the goodness of your heart
whatever the end reaction is that just
is what it is yeah this happened that we
mentioned on the podcast when we would
travel and she would do these
itineraries and in my mind i'm thinking
oh we're going to experience together
we'll see if we like it or not and if i
didn't like it she took it as i failed
when really in my mind i'm like no we
just didn't like it it's
it's what is what it is let's give it a
try thumbs up or thumbs down but for me
i'm like i hope everything's thumbs up
that's my expectation if it's thumb down
like which is unrealistic for her right
it's it's an expectation that she sets
for herself that has a high probability
of failing and it hurts like it's
something personal and my therapist has
told me recently
be kind to yourself marianne that was
the first thing she taught me
earlier this year and then now i'm like
you're we're circling back again
be kind to yourself yeah
and i think like one of the things that
she has to deal with a lot is
her giving
a lot to people
and then
people not understanding that it's
draining her right and so when i talk
about this and i talk about this
consistently when it comes to
friendships um
people confuse
friendships
with people who use them
right and i don't mean to say this that
people do this on purpose in a malicious
way it's just that sometimes we also
forget that
great i in my personal opinion great
friendships are reciprocal we both gain
something from this doesn't it's not
monetary it's not something it's but
it's it's some type of support or some
type of bond or connection that you feel
to somebody right and that's beyond just
bonding through tragedy
it's it's something bigger than that
right
i think with her when people kind of
unload their emotional baggage on her
she wants to listen she wants to help
she wants to be for there for this
person but when you start your
relationship off as somebody's quote
unquote therapist that's where your
friendship lies
i i've had this happen multiple times to
me because i want to listen and you know
me being being a youth pastor i remember
you coming back being so drained and you
would tell me that so and so just talked
about their life and their trouble
and i seen you
so many times i was like again
different person this time and you seem
so defeated
it's it's not even just like defeated it
helps it helped me reevaluate what my
position is in this person's life
are we friends or am i here just to
listen to your problems when does this
person call me up
this person only calls me up when
they're running away from their husband
when they're
yeah when they're running away from
their husband when they're running away
from their wife when they have issues or
problems that's the only time you call
me and then when we walk away i give you
all this these pearls of wisdom where i
give you my ear my shoulder to cry on
everything else like that but
when it what happens is like if i need
that same thing i can't get it from this
person
there's not there's no reason you get
paid for that then yeah something i
don't i don't like it's just something
like yeah this person just comes into my
life takes and takes and takes and they
think that we're on equal ground we're
not on equal ground you have taken and
taken and taken and then when it comes
for me where i need something you have
nothing to offer me so what happens is i
i'm more like your parental figure i'm
your emotional tampon as i call it where
i just take all your emotions in and i
get tossed to the side
and that's really what it is i'm your
utility i'm your tool for your emotions
and that you get to walk away feeling
better while i feel like [ __ ] and
they're not doing in a malicious way but
like this person i had to cut out
because that is the basis of all their
relationships is it how it started
when i look back at it yeah that is how
our relationship or what i seemingly
thought was us becoming stronger what
happened was that this person would
enter my life and then complain about
all the terrible stuff that was
happening in their marriage their
relationship or whatever and i would
give them advice i would give them a
shoulder to cry on they would walk away
and they would disappear and come back
again whenever they want to complain and
it's like oh we're actually not friends
i am here just to support you
emotionally you take from me and you
walk away and this person too by the way
all all her relationships are like that
all his relationships are like that too
you don't think that friend would have
accepted you if you came around and said
i need to talk
for what now what i'm saying is i have
nothing to gain from them
i can't tell them about my problems they
have nothing no advice to give me
their [ __ ] is always in shambles
[Music]
because i'm wondering
from their point of view
you could have been like it's give and
take like i do this but then you're more
than welcome to do this for me but then
from your point of view is that well i
can't because you can't relate to me i
can't get your advice because you're not
in a good place
yeah and they're never in a good place
right or i never know when they are in a
good place because they don't ever share
good things that happen in their life do
you see what i'm saying so i have no
gauge to see okay is this person in a
good state so we could talk about maybe
my issues or maybe we could talk about
something good or happy because every
conversation that you have with them it
has to do with them they are the center
of the universe and then if you try to
talk about your stuff they somehow wrap
it back around to them it's like
how did you do that how did you whoosh
you this conversation where we're
supposed to relate about our issues yeah
and then it's just right back to you
again and like i said even with this
person like you look at their
relationships now
no friends absolutely no friends
and like for me drawing that boundary
has been the best thing i've ever done
now in this person's mind they think i'm
an [ __ ] they think that oh um that
i'm just up and gone that i don't care
but it's like you have to look at the
history like who are your friends you
have no friends you have nobody around
you that's and every time that somebody
feels like you overwhelmed them with
your problems because all you do is
emotionally dump on everybody and they
feel like it's too much you call them
[ __ ] you say that they're
see i don't want to be that person which
is why i'm saying like i am these days
hesitant to
reach out to friends to like usually
i'll be like hey let's go and get coffee
and catch up but i'm i hesitate to do
that because i feel like i'm in that
position of like i feel like all i'm
gonna give is just
negative energy
i think there are people in your life
that you can do that with as long as you
balance it out with other things is the
is your relationship predicated on you
guys complaining it's like the same idea
that when people think that they can
gain freshers by talking [ __ ] about
somebody else it's like they get a
common enemy
right
and i've seen this too this person used
to do that all the time they try to
straight create a strong
bond between um their failing their
failing marriage by creating uh
a common enemy and so they felt like
their relationship was getting better
when they would talk [ __ ] about somebody
else i was like ah that doesn't really
work out because when that com common
enemy is dead you guys are just
you guys are just left with yourself now
you're left with nothing and that's what
happens the common enemy is gone
i mean that's why i i mean that's that
is the reason why i can't go i i'm
i'm nervous about reaching out is
because we don't talk about negatives
you know i was really talking about
problems but not negative i was reading
i forgot what i read it was like some
kind of it was it was a psych paper
basically on the
the the initial way that humans bond is
through
common interest or common hate yeah and
i think the strongest one was common
hate
right it's a lot easier to bond it's a
lot easier to bond over an enemy that
you hate together because you guys can
gripe about them and whatever but you
don't have to really be careful of how
what you say yeah because it's all like
yes hate that it's the same reason why
people love being the gossip person yes
right they love dishing out information
because they want to be the source of
that information it makes them feel
super important it makes you know and
then people come to them to hear more
[ __ ] so they feel like they're they're
they're the [ __ ] that's so corporate
like with oh i think i don't like to i
had an employee like that and i had to
warn her about her behaviors of doing
that type of stuff and i had to call her
out on that i was like hey
you are becoming a person in this
company
um that's not very trustworthy not
because your work is bad but because you
have a bad habit of telling other
people's business because that's how
you're trying to gain friendships i was
like by the way everybody knows this
about you they may not say it to you but
i will you know and at first you know
she got defensive and then but i broke
it down to her i was like the reason why
you're over here saying oh this person
is i don't know why is because they
found out the things that you were
saying about them when they gave you
personal information that you should not
have told to other people
right and i know that we all do that we
all tell like small little tidbits of
tough to our close and best friends and
they have to keep it quiet i'm pretty
sure all of us do that we're all guilty
of that stuff but this person would have
a habit of telling everybody that
person's personal business when they
entrusted the stuff that they should
have kept secret i would never do that
that's it's same in
like work environment too when i started
uh
working in adult environment i guess
i've been advised like be careful with
gossip groups and
and i didn't know what that meant i was
like what do you mean
um and sure enough
you could see there's like a group of
hens just clubbing yeah and then just
looking with those eyes and talking
about and getting all their information
of like what's happening
and like in one way people actually
get attracted to that group because they
want to know what's happening a lot of
the time it's about you know
who's leaving who's getting promoted
who's having like
interaction with someone you know it's
just they
they thrive off that they thrive but
also kind of like utilize that to see
how they can climb up the ladder or like
who's the right people that they should
you know be nice to who are the people
that should not be like don't need to
have to be don't have to be nice to so
when i found out i was like man this is
bad i'm like i don't i don't i just want
to be happy and so i ended up just kind
of doing my own thing and sure enough
something about it that group started
like reaching out to me i'm like hey
what's up like oh do you want to join me
i'm like no i don't want to join this
group but thanks for the info hop out
and
those who are not in there
tend to
they end up being becoming my friends
right and then one of the things that
they ask me is like you look very happy
which i miss this was
pre-coped like wow you look so happy
what do you do and i was like i just
enjoy my life i really don't want to get
involved in this negative
gossip world and i just want to do what
i want to do
because once you get in sucked into that
it feels almost like a cult you have
certain things that you have to report
back or like you have to share this like
information well you feel like you have
to add to the pot of [ __ ] yeah or else
they'll kick you out or they'll talk
[ __ ] about you oh that's like mean girls
well some that's what i'm talking about
like these
these
toxic relationships that people build
they think they're friendships they're
not yeah it's all predicated on one
simple thing like that friendship that i
have with this person right she would
take take and take her idea of
friendship is oh this person is always
going to be here for me i can't say the
same back to you so is it a friendship
is it reciprocal or are we friends or am
i just somebody around for you to be
there so you can dump your emotions on
me this podcast is brought to you by
skillshare my friends a long time
sponsor for those of you who don't know
what skillshare is it's an online
learning community that offers
membership with real
meaning and guess what it's the support
of fellow creatives on these classes
that empowers you to accomplish real
growth i love my skillshare classes and
if you want to know the class that i'm
taking right now is actually something
that's been helping me grow my plants
indoor gardening grow houseplants
veggies and herbs with ectishadri and
guess what my plants are busting they're
blooming and they haven't died on me and
i've been buying more plants because now
i feel confident all this stuff has been
great great great classes and i gotta
tell you amazing super easy to learn and
i don't need to search for hours for the
information when it's right there on the
skillshare classes so explore your
creativity at skillshare.com brain and
get a one month free trial of premium
membership that's one month of a premium
membership at skillshare.com
brain so we're not friends actually i am
your unpaid therapist i am your
emotional tampon you're gonna throw me
away and look what happened when i
disagreed with maybe things that she
said or disagreed with you know
lifestyles or whatever or disagreed what
he said to
they've cut me out and i'm like cool
makes sense now i get it right and that
person no matter what they do i'm
forever going to be an enemy in their
head
[Music]
but when you look at it from the outside
perspective if you ask all the the
whatever 30 or 40 or how many people
they met in their life it's like how is
it that everybody else that you met that
you quote unquote cut out says the same
thing about you but you say different
things about everybody else so there's a
common thing involved here you're the
piece of [ __ ]
so
and like i said i don't think there's a
malicious intent there's probably a lot
of trauma and other [ __ ] behind it why
that's why i don't hold any ill intent
but it's sad when i look at it it's like
you will never have friends because you
don't know what it's like to you know
what it's like to receive things from
friends but you don't know how to be a
friend
you know you see friendship but you
don't know how to be a friend
i see and being a friend requires work
it's a relationship it is just like our
stuff like we're in love this is a
relationship it requires work
friendships require that same amount of
work too
but when a friendship is good it feels
effortless but there's still effort oh
yeah you know my best friend we still
call each other on the phone he lives
all the way out in new york it takes we
we
and even if we don't talk all the time
all that effort that we put in was in
the first like 10 years of our
friendship so now it's solid so now we
know that when we continue with our
lives we're doing our other things when
we reconnect it's super fun and we get
it but it took work for us to build that
relationship having that connection when
you're so far away and you come back and
see each other and it feels like you
just met yesterday
i think that's
i love that feeling it's i feel like
when that happens it's like we
have a solid friendship that's what it
at least to me that's what it is if it
comes around and it's like oh hey hey
and you don't really have a
much to talk about i that's like
alerting for me like i think we've grown
apart friendships are sacred to me
that's why i dislike it when somebody
calls me their friend and i'm not their
friend it actually irritates the [ __ ]
out of me you have a lot of friends i
have a lot of acquaintances
and
i have like a lot of like surface
friends right which means that we can
have a good time when we see each other
but
you see them in my house they don't get
invited to my house
that's a very select amount of people
that i invite over for a meal take a
share and they and you and they get to
meet you and have a good conversation
with but a lot of the times they don't
really come into this circle though what
if you go out and see them
i could go out and see them because i
could choose to be around them and i by
the way when people say this when when i
say this i mean
i know it sounds kind of harsh but this
is the reality of the situation you have
acquaintances
you have surface level friends you have
homies and then you have the homie
homies right i've learned to categorize
these people in my life
so
there are people right now when i meet
them it's always fun it's always a good
time but they're not my really close
friends though like
80 of them aren't going to be at the
wedding
you know what would you consider close
friends is it like the longevity
or it's longevity because longevity if i
no that's not true longevity is just a
small piece of it right
it's
the reciprocated relationship if i could
tell them anything and not have them use
it against me if they could tell me
anything and not me use it against them
we can disagree without fighting
um
i know that this person will always be
there for me when i need them those are
the people that i keep in my life right
because a lot of the times when you say
you have clothes when you when you
mention your close friends
you also mention as
your reason why they're close friends is
because you've known them for x amount
of time it's not the reason why
they are that's i think it's the other
way around right
i keep them around for this long because
they're my close friends
not because they've been around for long
they are my close friends it's the other
way
they've been around for a very long time
because of the stuff that we've been
through how we've developed our
relationship how much they've helped me
how much i've helped them i could bring
them around my family i can bring them
around my friends like for example joe
i've now known joe for 10 years
jojitsukawa right joe is somebody that
is my close close close friend
when he has when he brings hannah into
this world his girlfriend
um
i see that relationship i see that he
loves and he cares about her i said hey
when you're in sacramento you guys can
stay at my parents house oh yeah they
did that is a friend
right i can bring you in front of my
parents because i trust you i trust that
you can be in this house i trust that
you'll be respectful to my parents and
you'll respect my family those are my
type bonds that i really hold close to
there's a lot of people in this world
and it's harsh when you hear people when
i say this there's a lot of people as
well you [ __ ] die could care less
like
just because we had a couple of good
interactions doesn't mean that we're
friends
it means that we're good acquaintances
and it's okay for you to call me a good
acquaintance too you don't have to take
it personally that just is what it is if
we spend time with each other we start
sharing meals we start bonding really
close something happens there then you
become a close friend for example
nick is now a really really close friend
right but it took him what four years
i've known him four years now
um
but we bonded really quick but even in
his case too it's like
there's something reciprocal about this
you know
not just the the fact that he was my
personal trainer because he helped me
lose weight and all that other stuff we
always have a good time
we we can talk about our [ __ ] we can
think about our ideas and things are
great like i know for a fact if he's in
trouble i'd be there for him in a second
and if it was the other way around i
know he'd do the same for me
right not because of something that he
could gain from me not because of some
social clout that he could gain is
simply because we enjoy each other's
presence and that's it is that a lot on
your mind
when you make friends
no because i don't care to make new
friends
when you start seeing let's just say you
meet new people and
oh like in the social oh 100
right like there's a kid that i met um
like he looked up to me a lot right
and like he's successful out in this
space too like in the entertainment
space too
and i could just smell his desperation
about how bad he wanted to be in my
friend's circle and it's like
no you don't get to be in my friend's
circle just because you looked up to me
that like that's years and years of
of work
yeah no
like the fact that you think you have
ownership of my friendship and my time
simply because
you know i did something in this
entertainment space that influenced your
life
i appreciate it but you are not my
friend and i should not be your friend
either
and this person got hurt because
like i heard through other people
they're like oh yeah like he's super mad
at you
like because he follows you you didn't
follow him back after you guys met i'm
like
what am i a [ __ ] 13 year old you
stupid [ __ ] like
the [ __ ] i don't know you i don't care
and there's peop there's close friends
too that i didn't even know that i
wasn't even following them on instagram
because i just don't care look at my
[ __ ] instagram it looks like [ __ ]
do i have an aesthetic to it do i have
anything i just post whatever the [ __ ] i
want you know and you and i are the same
page on that exactly like we don't we
don't really
put that much love and thought into our
instagram like it's just it is what it
is and so you know this person felt that
we were friends after meeting once and
this person somebody who likes to [ __ ]
on the first date that person will
forever ever develop false relationships
unless they fix that happen because
they're doing an extreme version of your
previous habit of expecting something
for no [ __ ] reason
it's like oh i met this person who's my
hero we had a good interaction we should
be best friends
says who
says who
yeah the fact that you think that you
have ownership of my emotions simply
because we met each other is [ __ ]
stupid and in fact you're you're
overstepping your boundaries and it
makes me dislike you a lot
i have similar
feelings but at the same time
different because
i am it's
it's not people's fault but sometimes i
get
i guard i put my guard up when there are
folks who
instantly become very like chinganet
very close to me physically and also
wanting to get close to me
and i think it's because of my
experience when i was kid where like you
know a student a random girl would come
up to like let's be best friends and
they kind of do bat [ __ ] and then there
are backstabbers so anything when they
want to like
all of a sudden become bffs or like they
think that we're good friends out of
nowhere i freak out and it's not because
they have bad intention like i don't
know you but at the same time like
whoa
get off well i wonder if people agree
right and this is for people who have
developed bad relationships over time
and learned how to cut them out one of
the the signs that i dislike a lot
and i could be wrong but this is just
from my personal experience
is
when i meet somebody and they spill all
their dirty secrets to me
i immediately walk away
there is something
odd to me for somebody telling you these
personal thoughts that you should be
telling somebody that you should
somebody you just met yeah and because
and it goes back to that thing where i
say where people try to bond over trauma
and they try to bond over negative
things yeah and that's a bad sign for me
because i agree there's this idea and
this is how i feel i'm not sure there's
this is just from my personal experience
of
if that is the anchor point of our
friendship
where i'm here to therapist you and to
listen to your emotions this is where
our relationship will start and i don't
see where the growth is going to be
because now you feel a close bond to me
once again like that one girl
you now feel a close bond to me because
i listen to your problems
right but
can i do it back to you
are you going to be there for me because
now i feel like my position's here and
your positions here and this is what our
relationship is now is oh i feel
stressed i can now call david so i can
talk about my problems thank you i feel
great can i do the same to you probably
not
you might and what was yeah i had a
similar experience now that i just
popped in my head i totally forgot about
this experience in college
uh when i went to
so i went to university of san diego oh
i should not say that but i went to
school that's fine
um how many years ago yeah and it was
majority it was non-asian so there was a
very small group of asians right and
i come from like 80 asian popularity so
when i went to that school i felt very
outcasted and just didn't know how to
socialize with these barbies and kens
and uh
i met a friend
she was asian and we became good friends
like she kept coming over to my
dormitory we like hung out like we had a
lot of things in common and then she
started like sleeping over as well and
talking a lot about her stuff and i was
just there listening
well
towards the end of it
uh end of that semester another friend
of mine was watching this and she's like
i don't know
i don't know about this girl she seems a
little bit off and i was like oh i think
she's a good girl like you know i think
she's cool
well
dory at the end of the semester
i remember this i was so pissed at her i
don't know why but i was so pissed at
her that for some reason i had her
mattress and her bed sheets in my room
so i
tossed that over on the second floor to
the first floor
outside the balcony because she wouldn't
pick it up so i was like [ __ ] this and i
tossed it out i remember that
so what happened i don't know i never
saw her again
she never picked up her mattress i don't
know
what do you mean you don't know i don't
know she never she never came around to
pick it up so i tossed it out i'm like
go [ __ ] pick it up
but where did she go i don't know i
never saw her after that what the [ __ ]
she when did she exist
i don't know i really like i i truly
don't know because after that i didn't
go to that school
so i you know i left that school so i
never saw her again and nor do i want to
see her again yeah but do you see like
how that how that happens and by the way
too this is not a blueprint for all your
relationships you there's probably a lot
of people out there who might have
developed good relationships after that
maybe that person felt better and they
started helping you out too i do have
that but yes that i absolutely agree
this is just personal experience but my
guard is that if i feel like we're gonna
get close very fast in a short period of
time that's where i kind of put my guard
up and like i'm not sure if this is
gonna be a safe thing to do there's so
many people that i've met that said that
same phrase right when they go oh where
they're like i met person and we got
close super fast and then a year later
they're not friends yeah well because
you didn't and it's not to say that you
can't that it doesn't there's not a
success story in that
but
when you connect with somebody super
hard in the beginning
you're kind of going based it's like
that it's like the uh the honeymoon
stage in a relationship you see
everything through rose-colored glasses
you don't know if you have the
wherewithal the strength to take all
this person's [ __ ] because you
haven't seen the demons that this person
has yet so when they say stuff like oh
i can't believe this person did that to
me what do you mean you can't believe
you didn't know this person
you don't know this person at all so but
what can't you believe
this is a stranger that you connected
with super fast over a singular topic a
singular subject maybe a common enemy
thing where you hated that same person
so how do you know this person you don't
know this person at all it's okay for
you to enjoy people's presence it's okay
and a good idea to have a great time
with them i don't think it's a smart
choice to go ahead and let that person
in your inner circle and know everything
about you when you don't know that
person at all what if that person lets
you in in their inner circle i think
it's still too much i think that we
should get to know each other slowly and
then see what happens because there's
going to be stuff that you know about me
that you're not going to like now let's
just see if you're going to be able to
stick around it's
i think the variance that's different
here is the fact that you are someone
who stays in one location for a really
long time
me i move around so much that that time
you used to though i used to yeah now
i'm definitely more i've never stayed in
one location for this long by the way
it's driving me nuts sometimes but um in
the past
i have moved around so much like even
after college too like living in korea
i'm just thinking about this one
friend that i got so close that i
actually met her parents and we had
dinner together and she also met my dad
who he came over to visit
um and we all loved each other we were
just like happy family good friends like
we really enjoyed each other's presence
and then out of nowhere
she started flaking out like not accept
my call blah blah blah and then the day
that i was leaving korea
she messaged me
and i was so upset
do you know what happened why she did
that
no
till this day i don't know
but see how weird that [ __ ] is though
and that these are the little
experiences where um now it
um these data that i have of my
experience and the cycle same cycles
that i've been having is now where my
guard comes up it's like
you don't get to
be so close to me so fast there are
people like that like i think
the way that we phrase things but sounds
really harsh like i think that's normal
though i think it's a good idea to
develop strong bonds over time
right
i think strong bonds take time
it takes
it takes a lot of trials and
tribulations for you to really figure
out if you want to be around somebody or
if you really like who this person is
you don't you don't know these people
yeah it does take time so like i'm
saying these fast quick bonds are great
i enjoy them there are people i met i
[ __ ] with instant like yo i [ __ ] with
that person but somebody asked me hey
man is that your friend and i'm like no
like yeah we're cool i say we're cool
there's nothing wrong with saying that
there's nothing wrong with saying
somebody's cool there's nothing wrong
with saying that you have you're an
acquaintance there's none of that [ __ ]
oh yeah absolutely yeah you know i just
think that people just sometimes take it
so wrong they go oh we had a good time
why aren't we friends because it takes
time to be friends don't throw that word
around so [ __ ] easy
that's why i keep my friends for a very
very long time
is it weird that i think maybe that's
just me being nice i'm like i really
appreciate that you think we're friends
like i appreciate it
i appreciate it too those who i don't
think that we're friends i'm like oh
that's so sweet you really think that
much of me yeah
but then i'm like do you though
i think it's just for them they just
like the quick bond and the friendship
stuff and it could be a definition
difference but that's true but you know
um
[Music]
it's like when somebody i just i just
dislike it so much like
because of the negative experiences that
i think a lot of people have dealt with
it's not about them it's about yourself
like i'm doing this for myself i'm
trying to protect myself not to get hurt
again so once again
it doesn't mean that i dislike them yeah
it just means that we're just not there
yet so it's like oh
you're a homie you're oh it's like call
me a friend to you
what's homie homie sounds like good
friends
oh homie is different like homie there's
like
there's like acquaintances
there's like casual friends
then there's the homie and that's the
homie homie then where's friends just
friends
i i think friends
might be homies friends and homies are
the same thing
that's a friend there's a homie
and then there's like the homie homie
which you know there's a handful of
people like that there's like
in la it's what
joe
bart you're gonna list it out now i
don't think you should list it out you
have too many friends no i'm talking
about homie homies there's joe
bart
khalif
is homie just men
typically for me it's guys oh geo
you know joe bart geo khalif
um
tim
ray doesn't count because i've known
race since i was a little kid like ray
to me is like family he's like a brother
what about your high school friends then
well i said here la
oh like but would you consider that
family or homie
what do you call that like to me like
the homie are the people like i die for
them you know what i mean
that's like my buddy will gabo
you still have a lot i don't have that
many well you weren't around enough
well that yeah i think like phoebe i've
been i've been friends with her since we
were in high school gobble i've been
friends with since high school he's my
best friend like
will known him since high school he used
to wake me up in the morning to go to
school so i wouldn't fail wait you've
known them only since high school since
high school yeah it was long
since high school well you know i'm 33
now so it's like
being around these guys i mean i've been
around since high school i don't have
any friends like that since high school
becky what are you talking about becky's
middle school that's great that's even
longer yeah but i'm saying like you have
a whole group of friends
but that group was even bigger
but now like the ones that i make sure
that i see all the time are people that
we see a single yeah and you know and
there's like the big friend group from
sacramento too when i see them it's all
good too but these people
specifically hold a very special place
in my heart yeah like william cabo and
phoebe i like how you could list them
now
yeah
i mean that's good
oh yeah that's uh
good for you yeah so like when like i
remember when phoebe had her when phoebe
had her first son that [ __ ]
made me tear up a little bit you know
because i've known her for so long like
she's somebody that i genuinely
genuinely care about right and so when i
see her kids her kids are like my
nephews like i i love those kids to
death and i've only seen them like two
or three times you know but those kids
are a family to me i love those kids you
guys all hang out together as it's all
separate
uh we typically hang out together
do you think that also helps with the
friendship
no it's just it's different like there's
trials and tribulations that we had to
go through like
being through their relationships and
everything else like that like whenever
we see each other like the idea that
somebody used to wake me up to go to
school makes me forever indebted to them
you know
william used to walk to my school walk
to my house
and i wouldn't be able to be a nice guy
and he would wake me up so i could go to
school what a nice guy i graduated high
school because of him you know you owe
him his your life you know like gobble
has been there for me every step of the
way
oh so individually you had like special
relationships you know sometimes if it's
a group like you're there because it's a
group something phoebe too like we've
we've been friends for so long we'd be
able to joke around and just kind of she
always allowed me to be myself and by
the way in high school she hated me too
by the way she hated my [ __ ] guts oh
how did you guys become friends
and why did she hate what the things
that she hated about me started to
become funny
because she was very serious about her
academia and i was a class clown so it
was two separate people yeah she was
like why the [ __ ] are you even in ap
class i was like i don't even know what
ap class is i'm here because my parents
made me you can't be an ap class there's
a parent's major yeah they made me sign
all the papers i don't know what the
[ __ ] ap classes were dude
so different i worked so hard to get my
ap classes and try to freaking pass i
don't know any of that [ __ ] i remember
when they're like oh you're going to
take the ap test i was like what the
[ __ ] is an ap test
i'm like oh you can get college credit
i'm like i'm not going to pass this [ __ ]
and i failed every single one really did
yeah i failed all of them i didn't know
i don't know what the [ __ ] any of that
stuff was i what what would you do if
you had a kid like you
i wouldn't know how to deal with it
because i'm a very self-sufficient
person when it comes to school
i don't know honestly i would just
figure out what their strengths are
right
my thing is too i would just want them
to always try their best if they're not
trying their best i'm gonna have a
[ __ ] issue you know like going to
school you wouldn't you would you
wouldn't be up to go to school
what was your reason for that because
you didn't want to go to school i just
didn't want to go to school yeah so what
if your kids like that too then we have
to talk about different forms of
education it's like cool well
my parents never talked to me though
they never told me why school was
important they never told me why i
needed school it was just if you go to
school you need you'll get a great job
but they didn't talk to me about what i
wanted to do they didn't know me
they didn't know me at all but i think
that generation a lot of i'm not i'm not
i'm not just giving them [ __ ] i'm just
you you were asking me what i would do
with my kid i'm hoping that i would know
my child enough oh i said i said because
i you know my parents couldn't be around
for me they were working 80 hours a
[ __ ] week my dad was a pastor and he
ran a full business my mom couldn't
drive she doesn't speak english he had
so much [ __ ] on his plate there was no
way he was going to get to know me he
didn't have time to hopefully now that
i'm in you know i am since i'm first
generation our kid's going to be a
second second well mike rk will be a
second and a second gen asian
i'm hoping
that he or she
would have a great relationship with me
where we can speak and i can talk and
i'll know how they feel about things
what they want to do what their dreams
are what if they are in their
what do you call it rebellious stage
they don't want to talk to you i don't
want to go well they got to talk to
somebody
like i'll say this though like my one of
my close friends she's a lot older you
know sylvia their their kids went their
rebellious stage too but they still talk
to each other they had their moments
where they were emotional screaming and
yelling but they did open up and they
did have conversations and stuff i hope
our kids could be like that
there's some you know i've been watching
some crazy shows of over it's it's
actually a very good show it's
but they bring really crazy kids it's
this korean therapy show where they
bring uh citizens with a family that has
trouble with kids and they record them
and they are horrible
i think a lot of people too like i don't
have kids myself so who knows i could be
talking out of my ass but yeah there's a
lot of stuff too where you know the
parents need to take responsibility for
that stuff because there's a lot of
stuff that we don't see behind these
doors oh no they totally see it that's
what the therapists do they're like it's
it's not a kid problem it's you is it
you as a parent it could be both it's
just like you don't understand your kids
issue
so you're not interacting properly where
they could
give you the right answer or like able
to open up it's just it's not they're
they're not doing bad they're just not
doing the right
they're not taking the rag
action but it's not their fault
no i don't i don't think it's their
fault they don't know that's why they
come and ask for help yeah 100 yeah you
know it's it's just difficult but i can
only hope for the best and
like you know we all we are all going to
make judgments about how people raise
their kids and i think now where i'm at
the stage too where there's friends and
i see them have their kids and now i
have to think about do i want their
uh do what they want their kids around i
was a whole number yeah another level
it's like do i want your kids around my
two adult stresses like no joke there's
just so much [ __ ] to think about
because i know like i didn't understand
what my parents were going through when
they were like ah i don't want to hang
out with these people because i don't
like their kids and they don't want them
to be around you and now i get it
i get it yeah cause there'll be a bad
influence on you and i've seen it happen
multiple times where that they were
hanging out with somebody and that kid
that was their friend they had a [ __ ]
[ __ ] kid they influenced the other kids
to do [ __ ] bad [ __ ]
do drugs and do all this other stuff and
this happened multiple times now i get
it
but then don't you want your kid also to
be aware of these situations no i mean
they're gonna go to school and they're
gonna see all the stuff and hopefully
we'll have conversations about it but if
i could choose to not put my kid around
somebody like that then i'm gonna choose
that option not to
right
yeah
oh my god
that's it seems like a whole nother
level of stress that i'm just like i
don't know if i could handle i could
barely handle myself right now you know
well guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast um
you didn't ended that well i said
something you're like well that's it
folks
well you i thought you were just kind of
thinking out loud i didn't know that you
were what you could say is don't worry
you'll do fine
well guys
that's the that's a wrap for genius i
know you'll apologize you'll do this
yeah this this guy he can't he he's not
even listening he's like well guys thank
you i didn't it's okay i told myself
this is what i have to do telling myself
you'll be okay
and that's what you guys should do i
don't know you wanted that to be an
answer i thought you were just thinking
out loud
whatever
that's stuff you do that a lot though
whoa
think out loud you do that all the time
that's what i need to do or else i'll do
it i'm literally talking about so we
were in glendale
no we're not we're not ending this
podcast because i need to defend myself
for a second
one time we were walking in glendale and
this is only the one example i can
remember but this has happened multiple
times we're walking and then she starts
bumbling off to herself right
and i'm like what's up and she goes i
wasn't talking i was talking to myself
like cool and then we start walking and
she starts mumbling again and she goes
hello i'm talking to you oh my okay
how the [ __ ] am i supposed to know if
you're asking questions to yourself or
you're asking questions to me
and she goes and what did you say
you're just supposed to know
you know what okay you know why i do
that partially that's just who i am but
the other part of me is because you're
always on your phone or preoccupied
or you're not
and you know for a fact i'm not always
on my phone i had the screen time to
prove it
when you were in hawaii oh my god don't
even do that david ridiculous
she always thinks i'm on my phone
because i swipe my phone to check my
crypto no it's not i see you you're on
your instagram you're on twitter you're
on my average screen time of day two
hours that was in hawaii by by the way
it wasn't it's too late nice try dude
you the the data says otherwise
and the data says otherwise you don't
know anything
i will fist fight you you want to know
that that's better i bet you have more
screen time than i do stupid i bet well
that's that could be true
don't talk to me about who's on the
phone i'm actually she's on the phone
way too much dude i use my phone for
work no i don't know she uses her phone
for instagram reels all i hear is swipe
some video and she goes
swipe oh my god that's so cute
swipe dude this dance is so cool oh my
god did you see i'm like oh
my word this is why he doesn't talk to
me and that's why i gotta talk to myself
but sometimes i just need response like
that okay like i said i'm like i don't
know whether you're saying things out
loud for a thought or if you're asking
me a question that's what's confusing
about you why you know this i like that
i'm raising you because you're making me
melt
[Laughter]
why am i making you milk am i too hot
i'm sorry no because you're giving me
heat for no reason for stuff that you
know that you you have weird habits with
you you already know that you know
you're marrying to a person with weird
habits i know so you know this about
yourself so you can't ask me why i don't
know when you're talking to me doing
podcasts i'm not thinking about you
asking i feel like
we'll we'll look back at the footage and
see where your eyes are at because i
feel like when you asked you were like
this is kind of off to the side i'm
always doing that
then how the [ __ ] is somebody supposed
to know if you're talking to them that's
why we're doing pockets we're talking to
each other so if i look up there i'm
still talking to you no it's not excuse
people people cannot ask i was like oh i
wonder what that is and then go back to
a conversation
well
sure whatever anyone could make their
own opinions on this
the point is
on the genius brain podcast i am your
host david so this is my sweat huh it's
not wet it's cold and clammy that's
different
put your feet against mine do it now
gross do it now okay no put it against
mine
no put it against mine do it now and do
it now i don't want you you have to
it's not wet
it's clampy we're not we're not going to
end this podcast unless you touch my
feet
touch my feet no
girls that's my feet no you don't have
my catch
what the hell are you talking about
here touch my face only if you admit
what
that he didn't respond and now you could
say
it's okay i said i didn't respond it's
it's there evidence is there
oh we're just gonna start calling people
out
i don't have any boxers on right now
because you
why because of me yes because of you is
your boxer's inventory dependent on me
yes it is oh my god you know the deal i
buy the laundry detergent i cook you
know the laundry detergent we're using
right now i bought it
yeah
[Music]
you didn't have to buy it i bought
laundry detergent what do you mean i
bought it
i buy the cleaning supplies after i we
did it we needed it and it wasn't i help
around the house i clean the backyard i
do all the stuff i cook
and i buy the groceries and your deal is
that you're supposed to help with
laundry and you haven't been doing it
and now i'm underwearless
my ballsack is not this
and you don't care
no one asks you to use all your boxers
within three days i do it once a week
every weekend days
you did this last week too you have no
you weren't even around last week i've
you know what i've been working so good
on my end of the deal that i even got
you food before i left so you wouldn't
starve
you know the trade-off
i cook i clean the back area i make
things nice i buy the food i buy the
detergent household products and you
just have to help me with the laundry
and now look at me ball sack out
oh my god
are we really calling it all out
it's so breezy in here oh my gosh
now you have clean boxers on the bed but
i had to do myself no i'm sorry i had to
cook this this this woman is so busy no
con you can't keep up with the hell are
you talking about lady you were laying
down next to a fire that i made for you
i literally made you a fire
yeah yeah what is this
what happened here here's the thing
though everything that you mentioned you
like to do it
she was laying next to a fireplace while
i was in this office working
excited too this girl was ridiculous she
she fooled me she made me feel that it
was going to be equal and now i'm here
doing everything everything that you
like you want me to give birth to our
child too is that what you want
i would push it out my butthole
and you can catch me at davidson comedy
and geniusbrainpodcast
well every thursdays and sundays for the
rest of this year until january january
we're going once a week baby thank you
guys for tuning in i love you very guys
much what the hell did i just say right
there i'm so exhausted touch my feet
before you go you have to do it ahead
sister i can't because i need to reach
my abs hurry up
touch my feet
what did i get out of this i need to get
something out of my ass can't take it
what up what can i get out of this just
do it so we can end this podcast
touch my face
see you guys next time